qui est préfet et ancien directeur du
conseil national des activités privées
de sécurité cnaps
et vous avez exercé cette fonction
jusqu'au mois d'août si je comprends
bien
jusqu'au 27 août donc vous avez bien en
mémoire tous les paramètres de cette
mission et le cnaps du temps où le
dirige ye a eu à connaître un certain
nombre de demandes qui lui ont été
présentés par monsieur benalla pour
l'exercice de fonctions d'agent de
sécurité mais aussi pour être agréé
comme comme dirigeant de l'entreprise de
sécurité
si vous le voulez bien je vais vous
proposer peut-être de prendre la parole
pour nous expliquer la nature de cet
organisme
les procédures qui le suit des
vérifications qui elle il procède avant
de délivrer les agréments aux
motorisations qui relève de sa
compétence
puis nous rapporteur g nos collègues
vous poseront certainement des quelques
questions alors je vous laisse la parole
si vous souhaitez d'apprendre mais avant
avant j'allais au m l'essentiel c'est
que je dois vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant une autre commission
des lois doté des prérogatives d'une
commission denquête serait passible de
cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000
euros d'amendé je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je le jure et vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les dessinateurs j'ai donc
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président
l'honneur de diriger le cnaps de février
2016 au 27 août 2010 8
le cnaps et tu donc c'est le conseil
national des activités privées de
sécurité a trois missions principales
pour lanvin pour les principales
activités de sécurité privée qui sont la
surveillance et le gardiennage
surveillance par des moyens humains ou
par des moyens électroniques la
protection physique des personnes et le
transport de fonds les détectives privés
et de nouvelles activités comme la
protection armée des navires depuis deux
ans dans ce champ d'activité
le cnaps à trois missions principales il
délivre premièrement des titres il
délivre environ cent cinquante mille
titres par an dont notamment des cartes
professionnelles pour l'ensemble de ses
activités et désagréments dirigeants il
délivre également des autorisations
d'exercice à la fois pour les sociétés
de sécurité privées et pour les
organismes de formation
il délivre ses titres au regard de
critères un premier critère qui le
critère de moralité et pour cela le
cnaps a la possibilité
l'habilitation même pour consulter un
certain nombre de fichiers dont le
casier judiciaire le b2 dont le tage et
dont le fichier des personnes
recherchées
et deuxièmement il délivre un titre au
regard de la qualification
professionnelle soit vérifiée par là un
diplôme un certificat de qualification
professionnelle ou un titre ou un titre
universitaire soit pour certaines
catégories
je crois qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler pour certaines catégories
notamment pour les anciens agents des
forces de l'ordre et pour les gens et
pour les certains militaires par
équivalence le cnaps ne fa le directeur
du cnaps ne délivre pas lui même les
titres
il propose il propose donc l'acceptation
ou le refus d'une demande de titres à
une commission locale qui est composé de
fonctionnaires de magistrats et de
représentants des organisations
professionnelles et c'est le président
de cette commission qui après
délibération accepte ou non le la
demande de titres sur proposition bien
évidemment du directeur du club
si la décision ne convient pas ou n'est
pas accepté par le demandeur il peut
toujours faire appel devant la
commission nationale
la cnacg présidé par un avocat général
de la cour de cassation et dont le vice
président est un conseiller d'état voilà
pour ce qui est de la délivrance de
titres la deuxième mission c'est une
mission de contrôle
le qnap se réalise a réalisé en 2017
environ 1800 contrôle sur l'ensemble des
activités que je citais contrôle qui
peuvent conduire à des à des demandes
disciplinaire les sanctions qui sont
proposés par le directeur est prononcée
par les commissions locales peuvent
aller jusqu'à une interruption
temporaire d'exercice de cinq ans et la
dernière mission qui vous intéressera
petitement est une mission de conseil
auprès des entreprises et des pouvoirs
publics
j'ajouterai simplement que nous
réalisions alors je dis encore nous même
si je ne suis plus le directeur mais
nous réalisons régulièrement des ce
qu'on appelle des rétros criblage et
nous revoyons une un titre est valable
pour cinq ans mais nous revoyons tous
les deux ans l'ensemble des titres en
cours de validité
il y en a 350 1321 mille pardons pour
être très précis actuellement valide et
s'il y a 6 est apparu au cours des deux
ans postérieure à délivrance du titre
une mention dans un des fichiers le
directeur demande enfin en tout cas
c'était ma pratique demande le retrait
les titres voilà monsieur le président
grossièrement dit ce qu'elle aime ce que
sont les missions du cnaps j'ajouterai
une chose si vous me le permettez
le cnaps des livres des titres mais ne
n'interfère pas ou n'a aucune compétence
pour la délivrance de port d'armes
c'est le préfet qui est compétent le
préfet ou le ministre qui est compétent
en matière de port d'armes
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'en parler
c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait logique
puisque le port d'armes pour un agent de
sécurité privé jusqu'à des lois récentes
et est interdit et il est toujours dans
la mesure où les textes ne sont plus les
nouveaux textes ne sont pas exactement
mise en oeuvre vous avez achevé
merci monsieur le préfet madame jourdain
monsieur sur madame jourdain madame
journal merci monsieur le président pour
préciser encore plus ce que vous venez
de nous indiquer sur la façon dont vous
travaillez et les pouvoirs dont vous
disposez j'aurais sauté savoir combien
de temps dure et l'instruction des
dossiers en moyenne et de quels pouvoirs
d'investigation vous disposez vous nous
avez indiqué pouvoir consulter par
exemple le méthane 02 pouvez vous aussi
auditionné les intéressés éventuellement
je préfère
le président donc nous délivrons s'il
n'y a aucune difficulté aucune mention
dans les fichiers consultés et si il est
clairement établi
si la qualification professionnelle est
clairement établi à travers un titre
nous pouvons délivrer un titre en moins
de cinq jours
si en revanche il apparaît des mentions
alors nous sommes obligés d'engager une
enquête administrative enquête
administrative qui peut durer jusqu'à
deux mois parfois plus d'ailleurs
puisque nous devons à la fois engagé une
enquête administrative
mais nous devons aussi consulter les
parquets s'il y a une mention taz ou une
mention au b2 et bien évidemment parfois
beaucoup plus s'il y a une mention fpr
et notamment avec une mention de sur la
sûreté nationale puisque là nous
consultons les services spécialisés
merci madame jourdain demander si
l'audition des intéressés pouvaient
intervenir le p2p niane a toujours à
contradictoires donc le contradictoire
se fait soit par écrit
il peut y avoir une audition c'est pas
une ne suis pas nécessairement une
audition mais ça peut se faire
tom jourdain alors entre ont peut-être
sur le cap plus précis de monsieur
benalla qui avait sollicité différents
titres auprès du cnaps une concernant sa
carte professionnelle d'agent de
sécurité privée je reste à voir
j'aurais souhaité avoir quelques
éléments précis sur la date de la
délivrance pour la première fois la date
de renouvellement quels étaient les
compétences et justificatifs qui était
juin à sa demande
et quelle activité cette carte
autorise-t-elle concrètement alors
pour ce qui le concerne le cas de
monsieur benalla il a géré omis de dire
que le cnaps a été créé en 2012
préalablement c'était les préfectures
qui délivrer les autorisations monsieur
benalla obtenu une carte en 2011 qui a
été délivrée par la préfecture de l'eure
et qui l'autorisait à exercer une
activité de protection physique des
personnes il a demandé une extension de
sa carte en 2014 le 20 janvier 2014 et
il a demandé une extension sur
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée la surveillance humaine et le
gardiennage le transport de fonds la
sûreté aéroportuaire et opérateurs de
vidéoprotection et il l'a fait
au regard de deux critères premièrement
aucune moralité n'a été n'a été vérifiée
donc il y avait les fichiers étaient
vierges et deuxièmement pour sa
compétence ou sa qualification
professionnelle il a fait jouer
l'équivalence puisqu'il a été
réservistes opérationnels et dès lors
une carte lui a été délivré au regard de
ces deux critères
il a fait une dernière demande très
récemment le 28 juin 2010 7,18
non non pas pour obtenir cette fois ci
une carte professionnelle lui permettant
d'exercer une activité de sécurité
privée mais pour obtenir un agrément de
dirigeants les deux critères qui lui ont
permis d'obtenir cet agrément dirigeants
c'est d'une part une fois encore une
moralité les femmes une moralité normal
si je fais les réalités une moralité et
deuxièmement deux diplômes parce que
nous vérifions pour les agréments
dirigeants la capacité de la personne à
exercer une activité de dirigeants et
donc il a fourni deux diplômes une
licence qui était une licence 2
de droit économie gestion mention
administrations publiques et il a exclu
voir et il a délivré également un une un
titre de master 1 en sécurité publique
qui était délivré par l'université
d'auvergne clermont ferrand c'est
pourquoi la carte les cartes
professionnelles à la fois une carte
professionnelle est un aliment
dirigeants lui ont été délivrés il a
donc deux titres
j'ajouterai qu'aujourd'hui enfin que
avant que soit mis fin à mes fonctions
j'ai demandé le retrait de ces deux
titres au regard de l'apparition de
nouvelles mentions sur les fichiers je
vous remercie monsieur le préfet madame
jour de la wii à aucun moment n'était
indiquée dans ce dossier la qualité de
monsieur bédard qui travaillent à
l'elysée comme agent public et si cela
avait été indiqué cela était-il
incompatible avec sa demande alors nous
délivrons une carte professionnelle au
regard donc des critères que je vous ai
indiqué sans considérer si la personne
est oui ou non engagé dans une société
de sécurité privée ou ailleurs donc à
aucun moment nous n'avions connaissance
où nous n'avions nécessairement
connaissance de son appartenance à telle
ou telle administration
et nous délivrons des cartes donc sans
même demander à qui va qu'elle est
l'employeur de la personne qui m'a dit
merci monsieur le préfet vous n'avez
rien à ajouter sur ce point un homme
jourdain vous avez d'autres questions
je me suis président sur monsieur le
préfet vous aviez été professeur de
philosophie et je vous ai demandé tout à
l'heure quelle était votre philosophe
préféré ça m'intéresse et vous avez dit
ou sol et nous aussi mais s'intéresse
aux collectes
vous savez bien que husserl à développer
madame benbassa le sait et d'autres
collègues aussi une importante
philosophie de l'intentionnalité et est
ce que vous vous êtes posé la question
s'agissant de monsieur benalla des
raisons pour lesquelles l'intention
finalement pour laquelle il demandait
ses différents titres ces différents
agréments neige c'est pas nous sommes
sénateurs ici nous n'avons pas forcément
l'idée de demander un agrément pour être
dirigé une société de sécurité privée
voyez vous et quand on ait eu chaud
cabinet adjoint au chef de cabinet à la
présidence de la république
franchement
on peut se demander pourquoi finalement
il y à cette demande mais cette question
ne vous a pas effleuré
et quand vous avez dit tout à l'heure
j'ajoute deuxième élément est encore une
d'autres questions après mais quand vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous n'aviez
pas vous intéresser à l'employeur de la
personne ou à son travail quand même
vous êtes un préfet de la république
vous connaissez bien les choses
ministère de l'intérieur la présidente
il ne pouvait vous échapper me
semble-t-il que monsieur benalla était
aussi adjoint au chef de cabinet du
président de la république
voilà c'est une question de se presser
quant à l'intentionnalité de la demande
les textes ne sont claj dès lors que la
personne remplit si je puis dire les
deux conditions à la fois de moralité et
de qualification professionnelle le
cnaps sauf réserves de la part de la
commission locale d'agrément et de
contrôle
le cnaps doit délivrer le titre et je
n'ai jeunes enfin le cnaps n'a pas à
aller chercher d'autres motifs les
motivations de la demande soit la
personne remplit les conditions soient
ne les oublie pas ce qui aurait pu
être ensuite regarder c'est lors d'un
contrôle lattes le titre d'agrément
l'agrément dirigeante
il date du 28 juin 2018
donc nous n'avons pas sûrs que nous
n'avions pas eu encore la possibilité de
nous intéresser à monsieur pénale
surtout que l'agrément il a il est il a
obtenu un argué vraiment comme tous ceux
qui obtiennent un agrément sans même
préciser si oui ou non ils allaient
créer une société et le cnaps ne pouvait
pas sauf contrôle savoir quelle société
ils allaient créer voire même s'il avait
créé une société
donc c'est au moment du contrôle que
nous aurions pu et d'autre part monsieur
benalla je les avais rencontrés une fois
très récemment aux archives aux dents
lors d'une manifestation sur les assises
de la sécurité privée
mais je ne fais moi je ne savais pas que
monsieur benalla avait fait ces demandes
particulières
ça ne m'était pas nécessairement
remonter puisque aucune apps donc il y a
un siège et il y à des directions
territoriales et monsieur benalla
faisait ses demandes auprès de la
direction de l'île de france
mais une fois encore c'est au moment du
contrôle que la question aurait pu être
tout pertinente au moment du dépôt des
demandes nous traitons quand même 150
mille demandes
il n'y avait pas de deux
signal particulier quant à ses demandes
ils remplissaient les conditions et nous
les avons vérifié je voulais vous
demander comment vous jugez de la
moralité d'une demande ou d'un
personnage mais temps vous avez un
détective privé comment vous faites pour
savoir il avait beau râle alors nous
avons la moralité selon les textes
elle se vérifie au regard des fichiers
consultés on est d'accord c'est purement
mécanique en dessous
sauf s'il y a une mention particulière
alors nous engageons une enquête
administrative
mais si les fichiers sont vierges
nous n'avons aucun motif d'aller au delà
de la consultation des fichiers non
seulement aucun motif mais nous n'en
avons pas la compétence très bien alors
la deuxième et dernière question si vous
permettez monsieur le président concerne
monsieur vincent kraz alors elle
comporte deux sous questions concernant
ce les deux demandes de carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité
privées qui ont également été demandé
par vincent bhl sur un centre ases que
nous avons auditionné
quand ces cartes lui ont-elles été
délivré au vu de quelle compétence et de
quelle justificatifs quelles activités
autorisées tel concrètement et
concernant c'est le deuxième volet de la
question
sa récente demande d'agrément en qualité
de dirigeant d'une société de sécurité
privée et d'autorisation d'exercer cette
fonction de dirigeant d'une telle
entreprise
quand cette demande at elle été
présentés et quelle suite lui ont-elles
été réservé le président sur la première
question concernant les demandes
monsieur crade a fait une demande de
carte professionnelle en 2013 c'est ça
et elle concernait les activités de
détectives privés
sur quels motifs sur quel bouton quel
titre
d'une part parce qu'ils pouvaient
justifier dans sa qualité de réserviste
opérationnel de la gendarmerie nationale
d'une équivalence
mais il disposait également d'un diplôme
d'université d'enquêteurs privés livré
par l'université paris 2 et donc qu'il
lui a été délivré dans un premier temps
en 2013 une carte de détectives privés
il a demandé en 2014
l'extension de cette carte à d'autres
activités
en fait à toutes les autres activités de
sécurité privée et il l'a fait sur deux
va en remplissant de critères d'une part
une fois encore la moralité vérifier
comme enfin la moralité au regard des
textes du livre 6 du code de la sécurité
intérieure et deuxièmement au regard par
équivalence au regard de son passé de
façon de son passé de son expérience de
réservistes opérationnels de la
gendarmerie nationale donc qu'il a une
carte professionnelle il dispose d'une
carte professionnelle qui couvre
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée tel que le définit le livre 6 du
code de la sécurité intérieure en
revanche quand à sa demande d'agrément
qu'il a fait aux le 4 avril 2018 sa
demande d'agrément deux dirigeants a été
implicitement rejeté dans la mesure où
on le
le dossier était incomplet et pourquoi
le dossier était incomplet parce qu'il
ne pouvait justifier d'une qualification
professionnelle lui permettant de
diriger une société
merci jourdas vous vouliez poser une
autre question oui merci monsieur le
président vous avez indiquée à deux
reprises que l'équivalence avait été
accordée à temps monsieur aka monsieur
crade en raison de leur qualité de
réserviste de la réserve opérationnelle
je présume que le critère est plus
précis il faut avoir été appelé un
certain nombre de jours quelque à l'oeil
critique
quel est le critère plus précisément
décliné sous préfet pendant
près de 20 pendant trois ans mais ce
qu'ils ont cependant oui ce qu'ils ont
pu justifier
en fait c'est l'article le ce qui
justifie l'obtention pour quelqu'un qui
a une expérience dans le vraquier a été
réserviste de la gendarmerie nationale
c'est les articles r 12 36 et r dos 43
du code de la sécurité intérieure je
sais pas si je vous en fais lecture ou
leurs toits
merci je préfère vous avez indiqué
qu'avant d'avoir quitter vos fonctions
vous aviez enclencher la procédure de
retrait de la carte d'agent de sécurité
et de l'agrément de dirigeants quand on
enclenche une telle procédure je suppose
que papa glisse mme des formes mais une
commission locale qui se réunit puis sur
avis de cette commission locale le
président du cnaps prend la décision
cette procédure prend combien de temps
là normalement la procédure peut être
peut-être relativement simple ceci dit
dans ce cas précis il faudra
nécessairement que s'engage une nouvelle
enquête administrative
donc elle peut cette enquête
administrative au regard de la situation
des deux intéressés peut prendre du
temps
néanmoins les demandes ont été faites et
donc sont aujourd'hui en cours
d'instruction auprès des commissions
locales
l'agrément est contre mais aucune des
deux personnes concernées n'a fait
l'objet de la moindre condamnation à ce
que néanmoins on considère dans la
jurisprudence encore récente du cnaps
que les poursuites dont ils font l'objet
suffisent alors retirer la carte et
l'agrément nous un e j'ai considéré que
et ça ne s'est pas simplement pour le
cas de ces deux personnes c'est le cas
général j'ai considéré que dès lors que
des faits était publiquement à tester la
moralité peut être regardée par tous
moyens
enfin dès lors que j'ai considéré que
dès lors que des faits était attestée et
que des ces faits étaient
déjà introduit dans les fichiers
notamment dans le tages il mais il
m'était possible de demander le retrait
des cartes dans la mesure où je
considérais tels que les textes
d'ailleurs sont rédigées je considérais
que les actes étaient incompatibles avec
l'exercice d'une activité de sécurité
privée je peux vous en donner d'autres
exemples a vu un agent de sécurité
privée qui commet des actes de violence
à l'égard d'une personne sans doute sdf
dans une gare que cette ces actes sont
filmés et apparaissent sur les réseaux
sociaux
puis ensuite dans la presse mon permis
de demander et d'obtenir le retrait de
la carte de l'individu en question
on vous avait appliqué une doctrine de
l'organisme qui avait eu à jouer dans
d'autres cas pas pour les mêmes actes
mais pour des actes
anciennement des duels mais avérés et je
vous remercie pas d'autres questions de
nos deux rapporteurs madame lherbier
monsieur le préfet la première carte qui
avait été attribué à monsieur ménard
vous avez dit était de 2011 il avait 19
ans 20 ans ou et 20 ans il est peu
d'expérience encore pour cette première
carte je voudrais que vous me donniez
quelques précisions et j'aurais voulu
aussi savoir quand la personne obtient
le port d'armes
la deuxième carte lui permet peut-être
d'avoir des missions plus élargie
d'avoir un agrément plus conséquent
est-ce que c'est noté 7
ce changement de situation avant et
après le port d'armes
ces préfets même un service sur votre
première question 2011 c'est la
préfecture qui délivre et je ne connais
pas la doctrine de la préfecture de
l'eure à l'époque oui en 2011 puisque le
club et le club ce n'est n'est créée
qu'en 2012
ceci dit l'équivalence doit être à ce
moment là reconnu qu'elle que soit quel
que soit l'âge de la personne en
question
il est majeur et il a une expérience
dans le domaine de la réserve
opérationnelle ce qui au regard des
textes lui permettent d'obtenir un titre
par équivalence sur votre deuxième
question il est bien clair que dans la
jurisprudence comme dans les textes il
n'y a aucun lien on peut le regretter
d'ailleurs mais il n'y a aucun lien
entre l'obtention d'une carte par
exemple d'agents de sécurité pour la
protection physique des personnes et
l'obtention d'une porte à d'un port
d'armes
et pour cause et pour cause parce que la
loi jusqu alors interdit explicitement
que l'activité de protection physique
des personnes soit exercée avec une âme
ce n'est que très récemment en 2017 que
la loi va modifier ce
cette disposition mais 2017 la loi la
modifie il a fallu attendre un décret et
les arrêtés d'application de ce décret
viennent à peine d'être de paraître ce
qui fait que pour l'instant il n'y a
même pas un organisme qui peut certifier
un organisme de formation pour
l'activité de protection physique des
personnes armées
ce qui fait que il pourra peut-être y
avoir des cartes professionnelles
délivrées dans ce domaine au mois de
juin de l'année prochaine
je vous remercie madame di folco merci
monsieur le président monsieur préfet en
réalité ma question a déjà été posée
donc simplement gelard formules comme ça
la demande donc de monsieur vénale à
être intervenue le 20 juin 2018 donc
postérieure aux faits du 1er mai mais
antérieure à la divulgation de la vidéo
donc ma question c'était simplement si
la demande était intervenue après le 19
juillet aurait-il eu son agrément mais
vous avez répondu je pense donc je ne
vais pas aller plus loin je vous
remercie
merci madame di folco ce préfet
simplement effectivement il y aura plus
mais je pense que la vigilance de tous
aurait été bien
engagé et il aurait fallu que je sois
alertés mais j'aurais demandé le refus
une telle demande tu remercie madame
mercier si monsieur le président
monsieur le préfet nous avait déclaré qu
il a été mis fin à vos fonctions en 2018
pouvez vous nous préciser s'il vous
plaît 7,7 fin d'action 2d comme tout
préfet j'ai été nommé en donc par un
décret fapa come to prefects gt2 préfète
territoriale auparavant j'étais préfet
de la haute marne
j'ai été nommé par un décret du
président de la république je suis à la
disposition du gouvernement
le gouvernement a mis fin à mes
fonctions je n'ai pas de commentaire
d'autres commentaires à l'écouté ce
n'était pas vous pardon monsieur
présence n'était pas votre demande
ah non mais j'ai rarement été nommé à ma
demande saas et ça vous manifestez là un
très grand sens du service public bien
nous allons à pardon madame de la
gontrie
excusez moi mais quelque chose qui me
qui m'intrigue
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la votre
demande de retrait des deux titres en
raison de nouvelles mentions sur les
fichiers est comme ça m'intriguait vous
avez immédiatement répondu par exemple
le tage alors cette demande et du 28
juin
mais je sais ce que je ne comprends pas
assez alors je comprends que vous avez
l'agrément pour accéder aux otages mais
je ne comprends pas quel titre monsieur
benalla peut figurer otage pour le coup
enfin
je ne suis pas sûr vous puissiez mme
étage normalement ses antécédents
judiciaires hors que je sache ce n'est
pas le cas à ce jour ce qu'on peut noter
cependant c'est que et on peut que veux
saluer votre réactivité puisqu'il semble
que vous ayez donc estimé qu'il y avait
lieu de retirer ses titres alors que
dans la même période
ils n'étaient pas considérés comme
pertinents d'engager des poursuites
néanmoins il se trouve que deux mois
plus tard il était mis fin aux fonctions
donc voilà donc comment comprenez vous
que cette personne figure otage je sais
si tant est que vous ayez une
explication le tage et est un instrument
parfois lent parfois rapides dès lors
que vous êtes engagés
ce qui d'ailleurs curieux que soit comme
auteur soit comme victime soit comme
témoin parfois vous pouvez faire l'objet
d'une mention otage ses deux lancers
c'est dans cet homme oui elle ne s'est
pas c'est pas la pratique donc dès lors
que vous êtes engagés dans une procédure
j'ajouterai que j'ai j'ai demandé ces
retraits lors le cas que j'ai évoquées
qui était un cas parallèle j'ai demandé
les retraits en urgence à ce que je
pense parce que la personne exerçant une
activité de sécurité privée dans les
deux cas qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
j'ai demandé simplement le retrait dans
une procédure normale
alors je peux pas je peux vous pouvez
vous donner les références précises mais
j'ai pas
merci monsieur le préfet est en effet le
ce fichier le taz est un fichier très
large et donc il suffit qu'une personne
fasse l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire
pour y être inscrits même temporairement
bien monsieur le préfet merci de du
concours que vous avez apporté à notre
mission d'information cette audition est
donc terminée je ne vois pas de
nouvelles questions
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup